G
MOMENT."
ENJOY.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR THAT MUSIC YOU
KNOW WHAT TIME IT IS.
>> FINALLY TIME TO DO SOME
DANCING.
>> THE WAITING IS OVER.
>> AND THE CURTAIN SET TO RISE.
>> THE MADNESS HAS BEGUN.
>> HELLO, FRIENDS.
READY TO MAKE A FEW SHINING
MOMENTS?
>> ♪ THE BALL IS TIPPED AND
THERE YOU ARE YOU'RE RUNG FOR
YOUR LIFE YOU'RE A SHOOTING STAR
AND ALL THE YEARS NO ONE KNOWS
JUST HOW HARD YOU WORKED.
>> YOU DIDN'T NEED TO DO THAT.
>> ♪ BUT NOW IT SHOWS IN ONE
SHINING MOMENT IT'S ALL ON THE
LINE.
>> ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE!
>> ♪ ONE SHINING MOMENT THERE
FROZEN IN TIME
>> DO YOU BELIEVE IT?
A 16 BEATS A ONE!
>> ♪ BUT TIME IS SHORT AND THE
ROAD IS LONG IN THE BLINKING OF
AN EYE, THAT MOMENT'S GONE AND
WHEN IT'S DONE, WIN OR LOSE, YOU
ALWAYS DID YOUR BEST BECAUSE
INSIDE YOU KNEW
THAT IN ONE SHINING MOMENT YOU
REACHED DEEP INSIDE, ONE SHINING
MOMENT YOU KNEW YOU WERE ALIVE
>> BULL'S EYE!
>> ♪ FEEL THE BEAT OF YOUR HEART
FEEL THE WIND IN YOUR FACE IT'S
MORE THAN A CONTEST IT'S MORE
THAN A RACE
♪
>> THE OWLS OF FLORIDA ATLANTIC,
THEY ARE HEADED TO THE FINAL
FOUR!
>> THE BIGGEST WIN IN HURRICANE
HOOPS HISTORY.
MIAMI HEADING TO THE FINAL FOUR.
TWO SECONDS, SAN DIEGO STATE IS
GOING TO THE FINAL FOUR!
>> ♪ AND WHEN IT'S DONE WIN OR
LOSE
YOU ALWAYS DID YOUR BEST --
>> THERE'S NO HOTTER TEAM GOING
TO THE FINAL FOUR THAN UCONN.
>> THAT ONE SHINING MOMENT YOU
REACHED FOR THE SKY.
>> HE WINS IT WITH THE JUMPER!
A SAN DIEGO STATE MIRACLE!
>> ♪ ONE SHINING MOMENT YOU WERE
WILLING TO TRY
>> MIAMI, NO MATCH FOR THE HUSKY
EXPRESS.
THE JOURNEY, IT ENDS RIGHT HERE.
>> ♪ ONE SHINING MOMENT
>> YES!
JIM: HURLEY AND THE HUSKIES HAVE
THEIR DREAMS COME TRU